hello everybody my name is Margaux how
to control myself this is a game that
I'm good at I say that
I don't know where to start on like the
stories of today we're gonna should we
serve them first we started the Legion
Park I won
yeah let's do it you don't still don't
know what happened to that bad not that
bad all right here we go
all right three two okay where you click
early why I mean I thought we're going
on mango night hero
you guys don't see it but I see them
from like the silhouetted profile so
here are some pictures of my markiplier
yeah record video I'm gonna show you a
side view while I kick his alright wait
sync it up for me baby
mr. Champions well is best two out of
three so I won - he won three so I win
so we're gonna end it on that bow for
all the poor hey what do you think of my
epic win in that one we never said for
all the beans that one we did not say
because it's my video give a Wade POV on
my victory here and there's balls out of
my head we're still rolling thank you
everybody so much for watching as in the
last one we want to see how you play
this with your friends and show us on
YouTube when you record this because we
want to see it
so we hope you play this just not
recording because it's stupid fun and
stupid fun is the best kind of fun
check out ways channel for more stupid
fun and thank you for watching